IT'S NOT.
IT'S PEOPLE CONTROL.
FOR THE LEFT, VOTERS WHO CAN'T
BE CONTROLLED CAN'T BE TRUSTED.
WHY HAVE WE SEEN SUCH A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN SHOOTINGS LIKE THIS?
JUDGE ALEX FAR AS A FORMER
MIAMI-DADE COUNTY JUDGE AND THEY
BOTH JOIN US TONIGHT.
JUDGE, TO YOU FIRST.
WE'RE GOING TO FIND A LOT MORE
IN THIS SPECIFIC CASE BECAUSE
USUALLY THIS SHOOTER IS STILL
ALIVE, BUT WE HAVE SEEN A PRETTY
BIG SPIKE OF SHOOTINGS LIKE
THIS.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS?
>> IT WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
JUMP INTO THE MIND OF THESE
SHOOTERS AND COME UP WITH A VERY
SIMPLE EXPLANATION FOR WHY
THEY'RE BEHAVING THAT WAY.
CLEARLY SOCIETY HAS CHANGED AND
ITS RELATIONSHIP WITH VIOLENCE.
I REMEMBER WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP, THERE WAS NOWHERE NEAR THE
LEVEL OF VIOLENCE WE HAVE TODAY.
WE CERTAINLY HAD GUNS BACK THEN,
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE THE LEVEL OF
VIOLENCE WE HAVE TODAY.
IN SOME WAYS, SOCIETY HAS BECOME
VERY DESENSITIZED TO VIOLENCE.
BACK THEN AS A POLICE OFFICER,
PARENTS TOOK A MUCH MORE KEY
ROLE IN EDUCATING THEIR KIDS
ABOUT RIGHT AND WRONG.
WE SEEM TO HAVE LOST AT THAT UP
DISSENSION BETWEEN RIGHT AND
WRONG.
THAT'S NOT TO SAY THAT APPLIES
TO THIS CASE BECAUSE NOBODY
WOULD EVER THINK IT'S RIGHT TO
DO THIS HORRIFIC ACT.
LIKE MAYOR GIULIANI DISCUSSED,
AS THE LITTLE THINGS THAT LEAD
TO THE BIG THINGS AND AS A
JUDGE, I USED TO TELL THE
PARENTS COMING IN MY COURTROOM,
YOU CAN DISCIPLINE YOUR CHILD
NOW OR SOMEBODY LIKE ME IS GOING
TO BE DISCIPLINING THEM MUCH
LATER AND THAT DISCIPLINE IS
GOING TO BE A LOT HARDER TO DEAL
WITH BECAUSE IT IS A ROLLING
STONE.
ONCE IT STARTS MOVING, CULTURE
DOES CHANGE.
WE SEE CULTURE ARE NOW VERY
VIOLENT, VERY DESENSITIZED.
IT DOESN'T PHASE THEM ANYMORE.
>> Tucker: GUNS AREN'T MAGIC
OR TOOLS.
ATTITUDES ARE WHAT MATTER AND
THEY HAVE CHANGED.
HOW HAVE THEY CHANGED?
>> THE SOCIETY WE LIVE IN IS NOT
THE SOCIETY I GREW UP IN AS A
KID PAIRED THIS GENERATION IS
BEING RAISED BY SOCIAL MEDIA AND
SMARTPHONES AND THEY'RE NOT
SPENDING ENOUGH TIME WITH THE
FAMILY DYNAMIC.
THE KIND OF CONTENT WE SEE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, WHETHER IT'S THE
HATRED FROM PEOPLE'S VIEWS AND
SO FORTH, WE SEE THIS ANGER AND
THIS HATRED THAT'S OCCURRING
GETTING INTO PEOPLE'S MINDS.
LET'S TAKE SOMEBODY WHO IS
MENTALLY ILL LIKE THE SHOOTER,
IMAGINE HIM ABSORBING HOURS AND
HOURS A DAY OF VIDEO CONTENT
WHICH IS WHAT I PRESUME HE DID
AND IMAGINE WHAT THAT'S DOING TO
HIS MIND.
OUR ACTIONS AS HUMAN BEINGS ARE
A REFLECTION OF WHAT'S SPINNING
AROUND UPSTAIRS IN OUR MINDS.
WE'VE GOT TO GET READY TO THE
BASICS OF FAMILY.
PARENTS NEED TO SIT ON WITH
THEIR KIDS EVERY NIGHT, GET BACK
TO THE DINNER TABLE AND HAVE AT
THE PRESIDENT SAID TODAY, DEEP,
MEANINGFUL INTERACTIONS WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
>> Tucker: JUDGE, WHY ISN'T
THERE A NATIONAL CONVERSATION
ABOUT THIS?
IT SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING THAT'S
IMPORTANT AND IT'S AN OBVIOUS
PROBLEM AND PEOPLE FEEL LIKE
THERE'S SOMETHING DEEPLY WRONG
WITH THE CULTURE AMOUNT BUT
THERE ISN'T A CONVERSATION ABOUT
IT, WHY?
>> I THINK IT'S A LOT HARDER TO
GET PEOPLE TO CHANGE THE WAY
THEY'RE LIVING THEIR LIVES THAN
IT IS TO SAY IF WE JUST BAN THIS
TYPE OF GUN, THIS PROBLEM WOULD
GO AWAY.
THE REALITY IS IF SOMEBODY IS A
HOMICIDAL MANIAC, AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
DOCTOR, THERE'S A SENTIMENT OUT
THERE THAT GETS CREATED
ESPECIALLY IN SOCIAL MEDIA WHERE
THERE'S SO MUCH HATRED IN
TODAY'S DAY AND AGE, IT BECOMES
A TRIGGERING EFFECT.
AT SOME POINT, SOMEBODY SNAPS.
IF SOMEBODY SNAPS AND THEY WANT
TO KILL A LOT OF CHILDREN
BECAUSE THEY THINK I'M GOING TO
BECOME INFAMOUS, YOU DON'T NEED
A GUN TO DO THAT.
I WAS SITTING HERE TALKING TO
YOU AND I CAN THINK OF THREE
WAYS RIGHT NOW THAT I COULD KILL
A LOT OF CHILDREN IF I WAS A
HOMICIDAL MANIAC AND NONE OF
THEM WOULD INVOLVE GUNS.
IT'S AN EASY ANSWER.
IT'S EASY TO SAY LET'S BAN GUNS
AND WE CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THE U.S. WITHOUT EVER FINDING
GUNS, IT'S A LOT HARDER TO GET
PEOPLE TO CHANGE THEIR BEHAVIOR
AND THE WAY THEY ARE RAISING
THEIR CHILDREN AND ESPECIALLY
THE WAY SOCIETY HAS BEEN MOVING
AWAY FROM RELIGION WHICH LIKE IT
OR NOT, DID SET MORAL PARAMETERS
FOR PEOPLE AND TEACH RIGHT AND